shangela yeah I'm so excited to have you
here chatting with me at BC Canada fried
I actually did a bit of a scoring on you
a few months ago which you saw and
repost it and that meant a lot honey
Live Love post repost like comment thank
you so much you know it's so important
that someone is out there sharing our
LGBTQ stories its spenders Jeremiah I
really appreciate that
thank you baby and with a platform like
et can of that I need you to tell me
where we are today because this is
incredible what is happening here today
in Toronto well honey welcome to the
skittles Hall of rainbows okay and this
is a great space that skittles has set
up and that they've invited me to be a
part of for LGBTQ to Plus weddings that
we are honoring today that we are
celebrating love joy and happiness and
I'm so throw the baby I'm just looking
around like what yes hallo hallo Leute
this is incredible I love that skittles
is doing this and I know it doesn't stop
there because I know skittles is
actually going to be sending how easy to
do to plus you to camp yes all across
Canada they are so I think it's so great
that we invest not only in love but
continue to support youth in knowing
more about themselves and supporting
them and living their lives out their
best lives authentically I think that is
so important message because that's one
of the reasons why I wanted to do this
series because growing up gay I feel
like there was a lot of representation
yeah I remember growing up especially
looking at television film and media
that there was not a lot of visibility
for members of the LGBT community so
it's great to have those representations
because it makes you feel you know like
you belong but you have a place in the
world and also it just opens up the
different dreams that you can have or
what you can be and what you can
accomplish
you hosting and unseeing weddings of the
sport couples it's incredible yes it's
so much you know I've always in my
career hope to represent you know love
and happiness and joy and laughter and
that's what your wedding a lot of times
are a lot of value a great time where
nobody goes away to an event
come on it everybody's trying to catch
the bouquet have a good time and it's
celebrate those two people that are
standing up and being committed to each
other and that's why when those invited
me to be a part of this that was like
yeah putting halle-loo let's bring it
listen you are just such an inspiration
to so many people and the message that
you spread his love and positivity and I
just want to know where does that come
from
because shangela is not negative you're
like no but you know that doesn't mean
that negative things don't happen in
life but you know I've others race or my
grandparents and my mom pretty great
strong people that are all obvious and
no matter what life throws that you've
always tried to overcome and completely
for with a smile so we're fortunately
raised in that way but also I will learn
that that's the best way to get when you
want our life it's didn't know that it's
coming and to go out there and work for
it but you also have a great attitude
while you're doing it or something you
said after you left all-star history is
stuck with me Oh tell me what it has
stuck with me it was the moment after
either burn
and you said I'm gonna keep my head off
I'm gonna keep it working
keep it movin to God my story is not
over
I'm gonna keep my head up i'ma keep it
pushing and I'm gonna keep working my
story is not over it's that over I keep
going my hat whenever I you know a
moment of self-doubt or feeling down on
myself but where things are going so
that's what I mean like the words you
say matter to so many people
well thank you you know in that moment
that's that was exactly how I was
feeling because I didn't want to be
defeated you know because I've been the
drag race you know I'll be the RuPaul's
Drag Race number I mean maybe even boy
you never know I can always come back I
was gonna say also too spicy champagne
but I will tell you that in that moment
I just wanted to I didn't want to feel
like I was defeated I didn't want people
who would follow my journey since first
coming on to drag race as a baby you
know started the baby I'm all grown up I
didn't want them to feel like one moment
could define you or defeat you because I
did that Keith I kept going it last year
I just completed a 184 city tour around
the world this year I started a new
podcast yeah they wanna be a feel all my
stars won't leave I mean my performer
Beyonce honey she doing it you are doing
it and like I want to say Gaga hi adore
they know me too like I am a huge fan of
her because I love what she represent
I love the music that she puts out I
love the way she unites people yeah
is there something when you're with dog
on that set that maybe she told you
they're kind of stuck with you today and
you still carry with you like what you
said stuck with me is that she told you
uh yeah because you know we had moments
between filming where we would have you
know would they change cameras around
you that so there was downtime and you
know she was so nice and she didn't go
back to her dressing room hang out what
she could I mean that's always fire but
she was like I what I hang out with
everyone upset so we're sitting on set
together I'm like okay shangela you know
come up with something cool to say it's
Gaga you know and then I just saw having
a conversation with her she was so
gracious she laughed and called me sham
they're just you know these different
voices you know gaga you had so many
amazing great huge moments Super Bowl
concerts around the world album this
film how do you remember all about how
do you keep with you journal and she
said you know I do
I do right but I also she told me look
around the room see my friends here
Richie's there Freddy's there Sarah
these people these are people who work
with me since the beginning of my career
and when I look at them I see the
moments we were you know fighting to get
into clubs or trying to get on to
perform and the journey that we've had
so I have great friends that hold on to
my memories
as well your life right now you are just
constantly moving and I thought that
I'll take a break this year I didn't
have you're not stopping so do you take
time to reflect on everything you have
achieved up until this point have you
sat down and thought wow I'm doing stuff
that is incredible
well a lot of times you know even at the
morning after Beyonce I got so many
texts about performing for Beyonce in
the standing ovation that she gave me
Chi and jay-z and I was like wow but I
really was already on a flight I had a
gig the next day so I literally finished
Beyonce went home shower got on a drive
that change and went to the airport
so I do general Andy Cohen told me that
he said Sam so make sure you know
writing down everything and one of my
biggest inspirations Jeff Lewis has
always you know journal she journal but
her entire career and then she wrote a
book the mother black Hollywood it was
easy for her she said because she had
journal so I hope you write a book one
day and that's what I'm doing I will buy
it and I will talk to you about that
book finally I want to go whoops bride
needs you a product to me means being
able to live out your most authentic and
best life out loud and proud pride means
loving yourself and sharing love with
those around you and equality pride also
is a reminder
to me you know this year is the 50th
anniversary of Stonewall and I think
it's so amazing that we had this moment
that we are here you know with skills to
be able to celebrate weddings where even
in some parts of the world there
gay marriage is not even legal it's not
something that people support or can
stand up for but it's nice that we have
that moment but it's all sort of either
don't here not to the place that we
would love to be in the world until we
are all free so we are all Street equal
then we all have to stand up we have to
have a voice we have to get out there
ready to vote if we inform it to be
involved and we have to make sure that
we are standing up and honoring those
who pioneered us to this point but
remember we still got some more to go we
got lots of work to go congratulations
it has been amazing to talk to you I
hope to catch some of you again soon and
let's celebrate on a bride